just me just Ricardo native yeah
what with the tribal people say about
just nice very honest ok back that we
start off with that I'm very real okay
I'm an alcoholic
yeah come on I'm functional functional
my I think I got voted like one of the
top fives on comedians really I didn't
press anything really yes okay well
congratulate honor then what does that
happen you said you know what this is
what I'm going to do with my life
oh I swear this is what I want I think
the feeling that I got when I finally
started doing it I never planned on the
community to burp the baby not a drunk
on how I got on say thank you Greg ooh I
started but no yeah I never cleaned up
in community my friends made me go up
one night cuz everybody was bombing you
go you could do that I'm like oh yeah
kebab better what but uh I guess come a
bomb better I'm a bomb better and I got
up there and I just loved it it was
amazing amazing feeling making people
laugh I don't think anything that I've
ever done in my life compares and I just
kept one back and then it's like crap so
like I gotta I gotta go back to my land
I got like so and that's how I know I do
I've ever taken Greg
this is close you'll get to it you know
what stage and feed that drug you just
re actually go it's amazing you're like
it just needs are we ready for the
Marriott already ready to write up with
just me thank you so much you so much
[Applause]
[Music]